oh they can't exclusive bobbin what's up
Jesse how you feeling brother I'm living
man hey congrats on all the success
lately man you've been no no you've been
doing your thing out there bro uh mom
now when I first moved to Vegas you were
going by dizzy D flashing mm-hmm what uh
what well I mean I'm trying you know you
grow as an artist but what made you
switch the name of specifically boy yeah
I mean it was mainly growth you know
just growing up you know dizzy be flashy
was suddenly I popping in high school
yeah part of a crew called flashy ain't
you know so we all had a love names and
stuff but it's just a part of girl yeah
I mean yeah definitely grown as an
artist when you know from what I heard
you were all BTW the wine wednesday
right yeah i was only twice twice yeah
and that was like four so you were going
like jerk type music right well I mean
just for us it's what everybody listen
to practice here of course I like doing
the parties and stuff so I got to see
what moved to people what do people like
to dance do and they kind of fed off
that indeed indeed and now you are dizzy
Wright you are a man the one joint that
I remember checking out when I first
came out here there's a few artists
everyone says check out you one and it
was I think it was like letter to my
unborn child or something all day that
video yeah that was a great record when
I was like damn this to him he's dope
yeah that yeah that unborn child is
about to be one on the total folks oh
yeah so yeah that's right I saw you I
saw between it then after you out comes
out of your kids yet that's crazy with
it's a good feeling so how are you 21 21
that's what's up man so uh now of course
you guys should smoke out how two
stations joint dropping on 420 yeah and
you're wrong with funk volume now I
really honestly um I've been up on
Hopsin for a while because I'm a tec-9
fan he he was on Tex album um but I
really didn't know what is the funk
volume is that a label is that just
click moment what is your level it isn't
and is that is that whose label is a
Hobson's just half a house okay it's
half Hobbs have a dance and hop is also
hard to sort of course yeah he's on the
double XL cover so shout out to him on
that the hot how did you how did you
link up with him in um you know I was
just doing my ground work and you know
they found me and I don't really know
about much what they had going right now
but they let me know and I checked it
all out and I was able to go to cali and
kicker what happened then I actually
they let me do a show with them and my
first show was endeavor it was on my
birthday though what was actually on the
twenty-fifth but we performed at
midnight so on my birthday and just from
there we've been rocking up so the new
project is an album is it a mixtape is
it a little bit of both cuz i know you
know nowadays people drop their albums
and they just put about freeing the two
calling mixtape so ya know it's an owl
so he's absolutely I get larger ackward
I did a lot of mixtapes in because you
know I messed with the samples and stuff
yes but because of it being an album a
lot of some of the songs didn't make the
album so I'm also dropping a mixtape
with the stuff that we make yet or help
promote the album but it's definitely
happen yeah sometimes the clearances and
stuff you know yeah it's yeah that's
what's up man no way congratulations um
what I wanted to ask you man is he and
you kind of have like you have a fan
basis you know unlike anybody else is
doing music in vegas at least and i
don't want it like box minutes vegas
rapper / how did you uh you know how
what would you say attributed to that
the most know having that that that that
fan base the arm I mean you have people
treating you free order in your city and
all that stuff man which is which is
squeeze it it's a good
I mean I learned from army all artists
around babe yeah you know everything
that was just able to observe everything
that was going on I think that's what
got me to where I'm at right now paying
attention you know learning from
everything everything and just being
consistent and you know not really
trying to be you know the person to put
Vegas song but you know develop you know
I've been focused on developing a lot
yeah it's been a dope artist and happy
to be free yeah definitely now you know
I put so much work into that I focus so
much attention attention on that that
I'm good now and gentlemen indie fascist
they're gonna fall solo dolo it's a
great record man that's a great record
and the video is dope um you have a lot
that the line that's kind of a part of
the hook you forgot it was something
like something about like it pretty much
did something i don't know why i can't
think of off the top of my head but
you're pretty much saying like you used
under swag to to get to kind of like get
the kids attention all 30 min hear what
I'm saying yeah appeal to the crowd so
that's what I'm saying cuz I know that
you're you to me you know I've listened
to enough of your stuff to know you're
doing the substance and sometimes do you
do you do stuff like okay look I'm gonna
wrap on this beer I'm gonna do this
bring the kids in to get them to listen
to the rest of the stuff yeah you try to
get the actual message home yeah
definitely I work your mother you know
that's when you got to be talented yeah
you got another saying so I mean that's
it that goes back to dizzy D flashy days
you know to jerk and all of that is what
got the party's popping you know i'm
saying i wanted i wanted to make sure i
could appeal to everybody you know i'm
saying so I know what's in you know I'm
still young oh I madera trying I still
got to be able to have fun to my stuff
and understand my stuff as well so yeah
definitely um what the album what do you
I mean what direction is that I will go
in and man is it is it you know is it a
cohesive surround are you doing like he
knows they're like party records is just
kind of um it's a lot of reality you
know but
I do everything I see it's more
conscious though that's what's up you
know that's cool that's what I'm doing
so it's definitely but I definitely did
mix it up and I and I made sure that i
did a little something for everybody but
it's really dizzy Wright you know you're
really gonna get to know me dizzy Wright
is and it's just reality man you're
gonna be able to understand it
completely that's what's up mates since
are you been rolling with the funk
volume how long you've been sighted it
sits like late November late November
where we had what we april five months
so far less um having like a cult
following that Hopsin has you know he's
got crazy as fans myth what is like the
craziest thing with experience you know
being on the road with him thus far oh
just a reaction of the fans you know
like especially for me coming out of
Vegas I was so used to doing so much
around Vegas first you know you know I'm
saying for people across the world to
appreciate what you don't you know it's
k some people get tattoos you know right
just how they react when they meet you
it's all crazy like the filling is you
know but I recently just had you know a
rememberable experience for myself you
know everybody new solo dolo this was
like my first time traveling and you see
perform it in the city you know that you
may know all the way and they know it
knows so that made me feel I never gonna
forget that that's crazy man so yeah
that's like you know s that kind of
makes you makes you know that you're
really you're on the right path it's
working like I've been in it I just went
to a city that I you know I don't know
if you've been to that city before or
you know if you had any sort of camp
over like you know these kids you know
all my words Minnesotans and I was just
talking to somebody about that yesterday
another already
you're saying that then I remember the
first time I did a show and one person
in the crowd noodle earrings yeah it's
now felt crazy one dude you heard of me
but then the next time you come back
this ten do you know yeah Grove it grows
it's all about the growth man it's all
about the growth so smoke out
conversations I started rapping on 420
on itunes gonna be like hard copies
anywhere yeah that's gonna be out copies
you gonna be able to get up at my funk
volume com so get that and if you
preorder you get our graph right here
comes out of that's a good make sure
you're on the lookout for this dude or
any shows coming up in Vegas are all 225
well actually is the location might be
getting switched up so I don't want
announced that falls right but uh you
know they can follow me on twitter and
you'll easily go maybe a Vegas our
release party yeah okay that's what's up
man why we appreciate your coming
through minute I'm gonna have you spit a
little some will we will come right back
might be spilled us off the show I'm
gonna do it man trace that radio bootleg
cap on i-75